you
hey what is up everybody and welcome to
the Rainbow six siege teaser dev panel I
am Justin Kruger your community
developer on Rainbow six siege we are
live from Katowice Poland from this
season three pro league finals and we're
going to be talking a little bit about
the teasers that we've been going over
for the past week about operation red
crow you can find a lot of these this
information from on rainbow 6.com / red
crow but we're going to be doing a
really deep dive into some of these
teasers with a little bit of a special
surprise at the end that you do not want
to miss joining me today we have some
really special guests we have miles
who's a level designer designer on
Rainbow six siege what's up miles let's
go man how you doing man good I'm great
we also have Simon who is the game
designer on Rainbow six siege what's up
Simon how much yeah awesome and we also
have may CJ youtuber extraordinaire
what's up Maisie not much how you doing
man I'm doing it great and how does it
feel to be in Poland feels great you're
polish right I am polish so it's like
coming home kind of my turf here yeah
nice your turf may CJ's turf and talking
of speaking of turf we have a really
we're going to we have a skyscraper
teaser that we're going to be talking
about and going into that so let's take
a look at the skyscraper teaser
now that was a skyscraper teaser we
released on a two-week about two weeks
ago miles take break it down what is the
story behind skyscraper our new map
coming in season four right well for
skyscraper rainbow six will be going to
Japan specifically Nagoya and basically
will have this traditional style
Japanese home that will be placed on top
of a modern skyscraper so this was built
by a Yakuza meta leader and it was
attacked recently by another Yakuza clan
therefore you see remnants you see some
weapons are scattered through the layout
so it's a full-on like gang where the
tick took place in there yeah you'll see
some blood stains on the walls and the
floors it's nice and some of the detail
in this map is some of the really
highest quality I've seen in past tell
us a little bit about the detail the
structure and the textures and the
architecture yeah well you have a
traditional versus modern E and what's
great about is in different rooms
they'll have some very iconic things
like you'll have a karaoke room Olivia
Japanese tea room you'll seat at amis
spread across the floors and you'll see
translucent walls like you seem to ban
so like the translucent paper walls that
you have in order doorways or something
like that or that's right yeah that's
really cool I have to say the karaoke
room is one of my favorites as we look
at some of these designs I get the first
time I played on this map I just got
lost like looking at some of the design
it was so beautiful and so cool yeah and
a gameplay wise there's a lot of open
spaces and we have three iconic spawn
points 1 which is the tower the
helicopter pad and my favorite the basic
skyscraper wall spawn point so now
that's a repeal spawn point right that's
right it's a very high-risk high-reward
it's good for players that want to rush
an attack but if they take that route
you'll be more vulnerable
they can be attacked by defenders that's
going to be really interesting so a lot
of interesting angles a lot of good
angles that you can play here a lot of
great rooms and and a lot of destruction
right talk about the destruction about
the map it what is it remind you of well
it-it's a lot of fun you know going into
these traditional style Japanese home
setting up a breach and blowing up the
wall it's great it mixes really well
with the aesthetic nice and once you go
from interior to exterior Alps on your
outside you get a sense of vertical
because you're on top of a building and
there's a little bit of difference
between night and day right oh yeah at
nighttime you see the neon lights in the
city in the daytime we got more of a
sunrise you see the clouds and so it's
it's a lot of fun very cool what maisie
jay is you know you got a chance to try
this map out what did you think of it I
like it overall it's fantastic what I
liked the most was the the balance of
destructibility it seemed like the other
DLC maps kind of struggled yeah not
having enough destructibility favela
having too much this one really found
the balance kind of like chalet I want
to compare it to chalet just because it
really has that perfect balance nice and
shalay is a favorite map in the probably
definitely speaking pro league Simon we
had we invited some pro league players
to try out this map what did they they
think about it yeah we did we invited a
couple of players to the use of much
else to do and they tried it out and
they thought it was like really fun to
play it really felt competitive it felt
more like one of the old-school map
classic maps or so like house or
something like that yeah exactly and
strikes like to them it strikes a really
good balance between the district
destructibility and you know like I'm
not destructible walls cool so that is a
look at skyscraper the free map coming
to Rainbow six siege in operation red
crow on november seventeenth you'll be
able to get a live show match demo
tomorrow on sunday as well where you'll
be able to see a couple guys play for
the first time live now also coming with
season 4 are a couple operators right
i'm really excited about these operators
so let's take a closer look at some of
the teasers we released earlier this
week starting with our defender
koo kanga home are you soon on the craw
how late are they
damn echo looks crazy would it tell us a
little bit about echo and that drone and
his load out what's going on with echo
Simon yeah well we're introducing for
the first time ever a drone on defense
it's gonna it's gonna change things up
it's going to make things a little bit
different right yeah exactly so echo is
a 3 armor one speed operator and for his
load out he comes equipped with an mp5
SD to as well as a supernova as a
shotgun as I mean weapon and for
secondary weapon he's gonna have the
bearing 9 which is kind of a machine
pistol like the macula van and the p229
which is a classic pistol nice and you
mentioned that the bearing 9 is a
machine pistol kind of like the SMG 11
mac-11 I think people want to know
doesn't have an acog on it no this time
around it only has like the Morris
besides I think everybody can be really
excited and happy about that for sure
great so echo looks really interesting
may see you got a chance to play on a
plate with echo what did you think of uh
it's a really for a dlc defender yeah
because this is more of a supportive
role we're not dealing with another
rumor here and it just adds a huge
element of team dynamics we have not
only the Intel but also the coordination
needed to set up those traps with the
defenders ability to stun using that
drone yeah and Simon tell us a little
about that coordination that pit players
are going to need playing as echo yeah
so basically how it's going to play out
is that like he's gonna he's a he's a
three armored guy he's gonna stay on
this side he's gonna hunker down
somewhere and he's going to go out with
this drone and assess his teammates so
basically there's a couple of ways you
can play out but like the main ones
would be that he's gonna go and follow
like the roamers and try to assist him
as like to keep em a lime or a life or
get chills or when the attackers are
closing in you can be like pushing down
slowing down the bushes with his sonic
burst ability which kind of disease the
his opponents so so you not only have
the camera aspect of it where you can
provide Intel to your teammate
it's but you also have a support aspect
with you know stuntin ability and I
think people want to know is this more
like is this more like Valkyries cameras
or is it more like twitches drone yet
this wasn't meant like as a Valkyrie
camera so he's the only one that can
access the the video feed of his drone
and he's not going to be able to mark
into it so he's gonna have to speak up
if he sees something he's going to have
to communicate super well so so
definitely not like isn't it's going to
be a little bit different from Valkyries
cameras where you can't mark and you you
know other players can't get get onto it
so you're going to have to speak up
you're going to need to use that mic
right yeah it says it's much more of a
supportive role that time around cool
and miles how do you think echo is going
to play on skyscraper and some of the
other maps well in skyscraper
specifically you have like two
structures are connected by three
different hallways I think it's going to
be really good for the early game to
scout out where the attackers are coming
from and in the late game it's really
good for those one-on-one two and two
situations nice nice very cool so we
cannot wait for you guys to play echo
and you'll be able to see echo on our
live demo during the show match tomorrow
right before the pc finals and talking
about other operators we are also
introducing habana our attack operator
is going to be very interesting let's
take a look at our teaser that we
released earlier this week
Bottas no tomo dad soon are a COI yvonna
taco de chi yoga
oh my god what are you doing Simon what
it what is that trailer teaser all about
and who is habana all about who is she
so first of all let's start with a
little back story so habana when she was
training to become a special ops
basically they were visited by the SWAT
and that's where she met with the
someone you all know a thermite and so
she took a couple of tips from him and
so she comes equipped with this launcher
and that detonates and can make holes in
reinforced walls so she's going to be
able from a distance and to be able to
breach those walls so that's going to be
one of our most interesting at attack
operators that we've ever released I
think it's going to change a lot of
things for how players are going to
approach a you know objective sites and
also you know how they how they reach
that that goal also how does it how do
you like what's the design concept
behind habana because it is such a sort
of disruptive operator what do you think
what was the thought process yeah so so
basically we wanted to have another
operator that is able to a breach
reinforce well like the thermite was the
only one who was able before before
habana so it's a it's a strategic
diversity thing like we want to have
someone else that that's able to break
open the can yeah not only one person
can do that now so that's going to be
your lab first thing you'll have a
choice yeah may see you got your hands
on play playing with habana a little bit
while ago what were your thoughts on
habana and how she played I mean I gotta
commend the devs first off because it's
really gonna shake up the meta here uh
she's really a game changer but i like
it because it eliminates that dependency
we had on thermite so I mean it was
always a problem when your thermite just
dies right at the start of the round
then your left not knowing what to do I
know and that thermite's usually me
right yeah like if I am awful at Rainbow
six siege now I am but I I think it's
gonna be really interesting and how do
you think it's going to be playing how
do you think she's going to play
with other operators uh well my only
concern is about Blackbeard it seems
like a very strong combo to have both
hamana and Blackbeard because he can she
can't make those murder holes through
reinforced walls black bear can be fully
covered so we got a seasonally nice and
yeah so talking a little bit about that
that dynamic what are your thoughts on
that Simon yeah well I think like like
every time you know the community super
like imaginative they'll find a way to
counter like these these new preaching
methods but you know like we're bringing
echo to the table and if like you know
with his sonic burst ability that
diseases opponents maybe black beer
won't be like you know too hot about the
idea of peeking yeah I mean it's my
favorite thing when we release a new
operator into the world into the world
of Rainbow six siege and the community
takes that character and and is it you
know they theorize about what this
gadget is going to be how they're going
to be approaching objectives and I think
the the coolest aspect of that is that
the community then finds ways to counter
them right yeah yeah so I mean that's
why I looked at the ground you know
frost is why I look at the ground every
time I've all through a window and so
I'm really excited to see how that plays
out huh how do you how do you think oh
and what about her load out oh yeah so
she's a she's going to be bringing it to
the table at the type 89 assault rifle
she's gonna have also like the supernova
the shotgun the same as echo and as
secondary weapon she will have the
bearing 9 and the p229 too nice so so
pretty versatile a you know at loadout
you think yeah yeahs she's going to be
able to choose like you know like you
want to go like full firepower long
distance engages with the assault rifle
or maybe just like get in there with the
shotgun and open nice being really
aggressive in a doing like a rush
pressure yeah cool interesting miles
what how do you think she's gonna play
out on on maps I definitely think she's
going to shake up the meadow and I know
a lot of people are worried about here
on out what I think echo is someone to
worry about really was that I think that
he adds an edge to the game that we
haven't seen before we've never seen any
defender with a drone and I think that's
going to be more dangerous than than he
bono that is really cool so habana and
echo are coming to Rainbow six siege in
operation red crow on november
seventeenth and and that seven days
early for season pass holders also
coming in season four are a huge number
of patch notes that our team has been
working really hard on and one of them
is one of the new features that we're
introducing or one of the polishing
features we're introducing his calibre
based destruction and let's take a look
at some of what caliber base destruction
is and Simon could you please explain to
us what we're seeing right now yeah so
as you know in the game right now you
only have one standard caliber size for
all guns and that wasn't really granular
granular enough for us so as you can see
there are five calibers now in the game
and each of them act differently on the
destruction system so you see like
pistols make smaller holes and they make
smaller collapsing pulse so and the
assault rifle will make bigger holes
because they're higher caliber right so
so the entire the entire weapon system
has been kind of taking this into
account it's going to create new ways of
people how they approach their murder
holes creation or how they approach even
you know getting through an objective or
something like that yeah exactly and as
you can see it's not only the assault
rifles that like produce big holes at
Eagle going going crazy yeah so that's
going to be kind of an interesting play
miles how do you think calibrated based
instruction is going to affect play at
how players you know approach the new
map skyscraper in some of the old mouse
well I think it's a great tool set for
defending players it's you know
depending on how they want to approach
it it'll allow them to create different
kinds of layouts to defend with but on
the attacking side they'll be able to
identify what guns are using
same time that's nice and and it's going
to be kind of changing the way that
attackers and defenders you know
approach their their destruction and
murder absolutely yeah cool may CJ what
are your thoughts on it overall I like
it it's a it's adding an additional
dynamic to the game and I'm actually
hoping that this will kind of draw
players towards the less favored weapons
we do have certain weapons that are more
more likely to be picked and having this
little element might change that up a
bit definitely adds a little bit of
variety and thought process to your
loadout and that's the that's definitely
kind of an interesting thought to where
you you know you may be picking a
certain weapon over another one based on
this new system it's really a polishing
of our system right yeah exactly like we
just said like delve deeper into the
system we just like a different like
calibers and all of them like just have
different hole size and and yeah we just
like polished in nice very cool so also
coming in season for our and is a new
customization for your operators new way
to customize your operators and we're
going to be taking a look at the elite
operator operator uniforms right now and
as you can see we have three that are
launching with season 4 we have cap can
there's a full head-to-toe a uniform
that customizes everything including
sludges unique sledgehammer unique
operator operator ability with a
sledgehammer completely changes the way
that looks and then there's also these
victory winning screens which are so
cool including that thermite one what do
you guys think of that it's pretty
pretty neat right yeah it's really
awesome I can't wait to see other people
win and with the street not winning
anything at all but that's really really
awesome we also have a other body BDUs
body dress battle dress uniforms coming
with these operators with a couple of
other operators in season four two of
them being exclusive to the city year
one season pass with the s80 operators
habana and echo they get a nice
exclusive
a uniform for the for the season pass
owners so definitely pick up the season
pass if you have not gotten that yet
because it ends on December first so
that is uh that is all we're going to be
talking about for red crow right now but
we have one more thing yes one more
thing one more thing to show you guys
something that the community has been
asking us for a very long time and it is
my deepest and sincerest pleasure and
honor to announce that Bartlett
university is coming to PvP finally
right so let's take a look for the very
first time we have a demo a show of
Bartlett University being played for the
very first time in miles why don't you
walk us through it this is a map that's
been highly anticipated by the players
and the reason why I was pushed back for
so long is it was originally a
single-player map that you found in
siege it was like the eleventh and final
situation of the game and because of
that it was heavily focused on single
player and since then we've decided to
open it up make it much more multiplayer
do a big overhaul and add lots of things
like lots of destruction lots of covers
redesign a lot of rooms and so that's
the direction we took nice and and and
as you were saying this was a PVE map
that is has been transformed and
redesigned for PvP there were a few
things in there like a ladder that
wouldn't really make sense in PvP right
that's right the layer is gone all the
smoke is gone it's much more clean and
we've also changed a lot of the textures
on the different floors so tell us a
little bit about those textures what do
you mean by changing them why did you
have to change them well since the the
original one there was smoke everywhere
it had a very different aesthetic so we
had to change a lobby excellent we also
had to make the different rooms more
recognizable for TV
and that's something that's really
important the players do need to always
know which room they're in so right
there's a little bit of visual language
like we saw in cabelas right where
there's a good you can spot out like
green red that's right way yeah so
that's going to be really interesting
and now tell us a little bit about the
destructibility you had to increase and
change some of the destructibility we
added a lot more destruction we also
added a entrance from the rooftop so now
you can blow up the roof and go through
nice and it's also got amazing it's
probably the biggest one we've seen so
far in siege so a huge skylight right
how your skylight yeah it's is it the
biggest one it's the biggest one there
far and also the longest building we've
had so so when you say that it's a long
building it means there's going to be a
lot of really like long sight lines
right that's right and also there's 120
windows half of which are pre barricaded
and so that leaves players a lot of
choice from which way they want to go in
so nice so and that's going to be kind
of favorable to a lot of the
destructible operators and also glass
with those long sight lines do you
absolutely have a lot of eyesight's line
of sight so nice very cool so you will
be able to get a live demo of Bartlett
University at the start of the show
tomorrow so do not miss that I know
people are really high for this may see
what are your thoughts on bartlett it's
been a long time coming I mean they did
say they wanted to release it people
already been asking for it all the time
so I'm just happy it's finally here nice
and I'm really happy too that it's
finally here Simon are you have about
Bartlett University oh my i'm ecstatic
ecstatic i think you share the sentiment
of most viewers in most of their
community so once again the bartlett
university map is coming in patch 5.2 so
with the mid-season reinforcements patch
you will be able to get bartley new
university and we are so excited to
bring that to you so uh coming up and
you know that's that's really all we
have for you today but coming up after
this segment right now we have the xbox
one semi-finals
to go who do you guys think it's gonna
going to take it in onslaught versus
supremacy anybody wanted to make a
prediction anyone want to be bold I'll
go with the supremacy they've been
pretty dumb in this skis and I think
they're gonna perform well nice miles
I'm gonna go with onslaught on slit I'm
supremacy here all right so i think i'm
gonna go with miles right here I think
onslaught is going to take it too so
anyway that is all the time we have for
you today thank you guys so much for for
tuning in to our dev panel and be sure
to tune in tomorrow for the Bartlett
University show match the the season for
red crow show match on the skyscraper
map with the red crow operators and also
is your last chance to buy the season
pass so before it ends on on December
first so you get all those goodies for
that we've released from an entire year
if you're new the new to the game or
you're thinking about picking up the
game you get all 8 operators it's
unlocked instantly so it's the best time
to pick up that season pass anyway thank
you guys so much for tuning in thank you
for all of us and we'll see you very
shortly thanks Justin